tinky winky dipsy laa-laa ho no those
aren't states of drunkenness they're the
Teletubbies the lovable chubby lumps of
living play-doh that live in a strange
land where the Sun has a face vacuums a
sentient and toast and custard is a
healthy everyday diet some enterprising
young soul has recreated the tubs inside
GTA 5 because why not I'm Kate and this
is your GameSpot news update having
already recreated the entries for TV
shows like fresh prints full house and
Pokemon in Grand Theft Auto 5 YouTube's
myrrh fish is back with another stunning
piece of work his latest video recreates
the Teletubbies intro inside of the
decidedly adult world of Los Santos a
side-by-side comparison shows that Murr
fish did a darn good job with this one
especially considering that he only had
huge beefy men to work with rather than
soft and squishy blob people you'll also
notice some extra flourishes thrown into
Murr fish's video to provide a uniquely
GTA spin on the BBC children's show for
example one scene shows Trevor acting as
tinky-winky performing a hand gesture
that might not sit so well with parents
in another segment Michael playing the
role of PO murders Lamarr Lala with a
blunt force melee weapon it's all very
funny and yet another example of the
creativity and ongoing commitment of the
GTA v community years after the game's
initial release one of the chief
disappointments of my childhood was
being too old to truly enjoy Teletubbies
Murphy wrote in the video's description
oh the life I could have lived have this
ruined children's TV for you forever let
us know in the comments or come find me
on Twitter at how not to troll
I'm Kate and remember to keep it
gamespot.com for all your Teletubbies
slash video game updates
[Music]